all right I'll or podcast Lords a gaming
dotnet we are here at a very unique
title who's just fine gentlemen in the
realm today Wow now this game I have to
admit the art style looks absolutely
fantastic and this is a sequel I'm
completely new to this game so please
educate me on one finger death punch
what is the premise and certainly is the
fastest brawler ever made the fastest
yeah it really is the best brother a
challenge anyone to show me at all or
talking that talk I love that the top
I'm old but I'm a lord of the realm I
grew up on 70s kung-fu flicks right now
and a lot of this gives me that kind of
a vibe can you give me like maybe some
inspirations behind just a whole design
of the game you know that whole motif
about it yeah this game all the
inspiration came from movies in fact
Bruce Lee's Fist of Fury where he takes
on an entire dojo oh that was him versus
all of them and he uses different
weapons everything to to do it is this
is him versus all the men and I also
mentioned I I should mention Jet Li's
the one Wow all the other Gentiles and
there's only two left and the evil
gently gets sent to a prison and he's on
top of a pyramid and he's fighting a
thousand prisoners that is this one man
fighting a thousand enemies from
different angles so that you know the
core in the inspiration comes from those
two belts I'm so glad you said that
because again a lot of our core we grew
up on those style flicks the Jet Li's
the Bruce leads the run run Shaw kind of
films I mean it's the essence of it so
as far as the to button mechanic now
let's get into mechanics itself like I
noticed like I said the enemies are
coming at you it's one button which
strikes or is it blocking tell me like
the basic gameplay as you progress
fighting all these enemies okay
so when enemy enters I guess it's close
to you all right right or the left side
then that side lights up saying it's now
a valid target press me and essentially
the character will do a finishing move
if they only ask if one life lasts more
it could do anything like a flaw ahead
so if you have a four hit enemy on one
side and you gotta hit him four times
most games would have you punching them
four times but not this game this game
your first attack could be a block hit
blah finish and get some food yeah yeah
have you ever watched Street Fighter
highest level is pretty freakin sick
looking just regular street fighters not
a lot of blocking going on it's back in
for the exactly so we create with some
of these enemies to do that very thing
back and forth you you literally just
captured the essence again of that
martial arts that back it's never just
punch punch punch again when you watch
those films is literally what you said
that back and forth it really gives you
the essence of being in a fight and that
exchange of the arts I love what you're
going with man now as far as level
design how much levels are currently in
one finger death punch we have 13
different game modes in there you're
fighting a bunch of dudes and you play
more dues I like that fight but there is
one cool thing about about one of the
game modes we added in there an example
of what we try to do with kungfu is our
drunken master levels you have your guy
in the middle he's drunk and those bars
on the left and right
zwei it gets wider on one shorter on the
other wider none and that kind of really
incorporates that theme of drunken
master the second example is the Wing
Chun style it's a close combat style of
fighting
so we shortened those bars up and make
it so a lot of your attacks or as winch
on top of breaking limbs and things yeah
though you are capturing the essence of
our Schloss I'm loving this man now
off-camera we've talked a little bit
about twitch integration and things that
you guys are discussing about that now
is that still currently in game or
something that's gonna be plan for the
future it's it's kind of a versus the
player scenario where the chat can queue
up some stuff become a character in the
game just visually just visual fun
and if the chat lands a hit on the
player the chat scores a point wow
that's cool that is really cool so again
we're looking at that April you said
15th you said April 14 launch now I
gotta say this game in my opinion I'm a
huge switch fan and my figure I think
this would be a killer game on a switch
or even any other platform is there any
plans to expand it maybe two the
consoles at some point yeah it is coming
to Xbox and the switch
we hear that kind of done at some point
maybe September if we're lucky and ps4
is gonna follow after that so Xbox first
hopefully hecklers switch at the same
time this is awesome super excited
cannot wait to learn more about this
game and what a just one more question
what did you learn about the initial
because obvious a sequel I'm new to the
game right so what did you learn from
the first iteration of this game so now
the sequel and there was a few we just
couldn't iron them out in this game we
have about 50 or 60 little subtle things
that we do to make the gameplay fair in
all circumstances no matter how fast
it's going and it could go blazing fast
and I think making every element seem
completely fair we're know I got screwed
that is not gonna happen if if if you
miss or got hit I want the game to make
sure that you felt like you made that
error and the game didn't do that to you
that's awesome and it's actually it's
fair and it shows balance which is what
I like and the last thing I'll say is I
love the inclusion of weapons and how
visceral the game is like tell me about
like I said he's blocking ninja stars
and doing that kind of stuff and both
what other weapons do we have in the
game you know it's just visual flair but
they're putting away you transition from
weapon to weapon you
pick up a weapon quite a bit drop it
pick up another weapon rapid dagger
throw that it kind of mimics the idea of
a Jackie Chan film where he's fighting
someone and he's you know using a frying
pan to play someone off while cooking
eggs with another frying pan and then
these finishes how many finishes his
eggs that kind of humor and and and
complex evil scenes we're trying to
incorporate in this game I am absolutely
loving the fact that your representation
of martial arts in this game is is so
cool do we cannot wait again April on
our scheme okay April 15th on steam then
we're doing Xbox and switch hopefully
later of the year and then hopefully
again ps4 afterwards right awesome one
finger death punch this is one of my
favorite games to show it I'm a
podcaster pool we can't wait to learn
more thank you so much